foreign
I do have something fun for us
yeah I do and I promised it Friday now
[Music]
as promised we do have a video of him
more video of him
um interviewing
um Prince Harry but before this is a
little quick one
this is Skip Bayless this Sunday
addressing the Skip Bayless tweet
without you know saying it
here you go
and and you spoke about humanity and I
think but there were things done here by
someone here at this network that were
inhumane
inhumane are we in a world where we have
to defend Skip Bayless to Michael
Strahan because I don't like that
position that I'm in right now I don't
like this that makes you feel
uncomfortable sir
I I think you're using the word because
Michael Strahan obviously not a Rhodes
scholar
um not even a member of the Rhodes
family frankly but uh or the Road
Warriors he does sound like he's in the
from the Rhodes family he does yeah oh
my God he does but uh how 10th baby sir
I think when you sit inhumane I think
you mentioned I'll give you insensitive
I would say anyone's saying what Skip
Bayless said was insensitive fair enough
that's a fair assessment you know you're
being level-headed but inhumane you're
making it sound like Skip Bayless is
murdering interns
he's not Joe Scarborough
sit here and we talk about how good and
I'm sorry to take it this way but this
this route but I just I just felt like
sensible people and sensible human
beings have a heart and they understand
oh not if they took the vax yeah and not
when they have like [ __ ] 20 grand on
the game and that that your words and
what you say really have an impact not
only dude if I had like a couple Grand
on that game I probably would have been
tweeting like let's go come on you got
[ __ ] can you make [ __ ] 11 players
show up on the field please let's go
come on family and and and so all the
attention should be on this young man
his recovery for offensible people like
us here to say that it didn't affect
anybody at this network nobody is
Network minded that's a lie obviously
didn't talk to us yeah okay I hear what
you're saying Michael and I actually do
like your bud but here's the thing
how come none of you how come all the
people that were screaming about getting
the vaccine how come you weren't on
their side how come you weren't how come
you weren't standing up for Beasley
being when were Beasley from the bills
we wouldn't take the vax and then how
come you don't worry about him how can
we worry about Aaron Rodgers about these
people that were [ __ ] blacklisted for
not taking this see that's the point
though at least be consistent all right
because it matters to us and it matters
to any sensible human being that this
young man's life was bigger than any
football game but this young man will
hopefully be back and forget about
football but just have a life and his
family has him that's the most important
thing and and I think that was kind of
Amen well let's say that let's say that
um
this heart problem that
[ __ ] you we know what happened we know
where it came from anybody that says
different listen I think the vaccine
caused this man to have a heart attack I
don't care what microscopic thing you
got to say and I'm allowed to think that
so suck my dick if you don't like it
how's that and I don't like the fact
that you're gonna turn him into some
kind of little Survivor propaganda guy
and he's going to be just some sort of
media influencer now yeah okay fine you
won the game of life but you guys still
took the one gift he had from him at the
beginning of his career right like
that's a [ __ ] up thing like I know we
all [ __ ] on athletes so good they get
millions of dollars to chase a ball
around right but we still enjoy watching
a young player like succeed and you're
like oh man this you know what I mean
you wanna you know I root for people on
my team like you want to see some people
do good and when you take like the one
thing a guy worked his whole life for
away from him at 24. even if he gets to
live you're gonna sell it like oh what a
miraculous thing he's alive and he gets
to live life I've not worry about
football the problem is football is all
he has and that's what makes him he just
[ __ ] him out of it
mm-hmm
uh well
and now to more of my one-on-one
conversation with Prince Harry ahead of
his new Memoir he really is I mean you
got to say I'm and he's funny but we
thought he really is like the propaganda
guy they should out there for all these
things huh like even now with the Prince
Harry thinks spare but can we before we
get into the Michael Strahan thing we
talked about this Friday but I gotta
reiterate he's the spare Prince man it
must have been so hard to be in a royal
family with millions of dollars yeah
Prince Charles wasn't your dad what do
you want you're lucky you got to live in
the house Jon Snow I was gonna see the
[ __ ] Jon Snow [ __ ] and now
you're like they even gave you the last
name and you got to drive around and you
[ __ ] he is Jon Snow and he simped out
to a [ __ ] just like Jon Snow did holy
[ __ ] he's Jon Snow and the end of his
story just sucks this is disappointing
yeah and he's he's with Merkel which
basically means you know to though they
call them wildling so he banged the
wildling that makes sense it's just like
Jon Snow think about it right he started
off promising with the Nazi outfits and
the bad bad [ __ ] behavior and you're
like oh this guy's kind of a badass a
nice complete [ __ ] and his story just
petered out yeah instead of doing like
some cool Game of Thrones [ __ ] where you
throw a red wedding to kill your of
instead you just cry on [ __ ] Good
Morning America oh that's a [ __ ] cuck
are spare he opened up to me about his
mental health struggles how he didn't
cry for a decade after losing his mother
Princess Diana and the moment he truly
accepted her death and how he still
fills her presence today
take a look
if the image seared into so many Minds
twelve-year-old Prince Harry and 15 year
old Prince William heads bowed walking
behind a horse-drawn carriage holding
their mother's coffin he said you didn't
cry
for years I didn't the first time I
cried because I don't actually have any
feelings and I look like I should be uh
who's who's the [ __ ] the ginger
singer the Ed Sheeran he looks like a
train [ __ ] out of here
I was uh uh at the burial but then after
that after that for years
why uh well it's because
um I'm a Darkness it will so psychopath
um makes sense I know this
wasn't through lack of trying
believe me I tried but there was there
was nothing there it was it was I was
numb his new Memoir spare Harry's
described in the morning of August 31st
1997 when his father now King Charles
delivered the devastating news that
Prince of Diana was murdered by the
queen I'm sorry what um was killed in by
the paparazzi's chasing her in a car
accident uh in a tunnel that nobody has
ever died in before or since yeah was
with some mysterious Saudi billionaire
yeah it was
right had been killed in a Paris car
crash as a dad I would never ever
let my kid go through a tunnel ever
again what won't I have to break that
news ever so I have a huge amount of
sympathy and compassion and
understanding now
about how inequipped I guess right but
you're now you've been going around and
[ __ ] on your dad on local news
because you and your brother had a
scuffle because you two brothers fought
like a Brothers do all the time yeah and
also this is all just like [ __ ] Jerry
Springer drama to sell a book you don't
really want to take your family down
because if so let's get into your uncle
can we talk about Unk no we're talking
about Uncle Andrew
telling stories about him didn't he say
something about killing a bunch of
afghanis Prince Harry before we play the
because this is all connected so Strahan
sit tight for a second I don't have
anywhere to be
um there have been more stunning
Revelations overnight from Prince
Harry's autobiography it's due to be
published next week and accompanied by
some have you seen a full court wrestler
A Book Like This
it's been a long time I mean I'm trying
to think of the last one yes I have but
it's been a while uh Como's book how I
did the pandemic that's when they still
liked them so yes Como's book yeah Harry
uh claims Harry's claims I should say
are offering a devastating insight into
the Royal life Andrew
from London oh no even funnier on among
the many dropped bombs in Prince Harry's
tell-all Memoir he reveals that he and
Prince William begged his father King
Charles not to marry Camilla now Queen
consort and how he spoke with his
deceased mother Diana through a medium
his reported so wait you bet your dad
not to marry his new wife while at the
same time being mad that your parents
didn't want you to marry your [ __ ] wife
you don't see the issue here
the ghost written books spare largely
focuses on just that being the spare did
he say the girl ghost ghost written book
is that what he said just straight up
hold on well this is local news they
don't have the same yeah because you
know what local how many times have we
seen this local news always lets more
stuff slip because it takes longer it
takes longer to get the the propaganda
this hilarious through a medium his
reportedly ghosted why he used The Ghost
Writer Prince Harry said why would I use
a pen I'm not a Jewish girl in an attic
that's fair that's true a medium his
reportedly ghost written books yes
that's right it was written by ghosts is
written by the ghost of me Mom
largely focuses on just that Harry I got
a question
do any of these [ __ ] ever come out of
your book and shoot a big [ __ ] shot on
your mom
you just can't change the rules because
you don't like how I'm doing it hey uh
Harry real quick I haven't read your
book yet but at any point in the book do
you uh do any of these [ __ ] go like
oh [ __ ] it's a big [ __ ] fat horse
[ __ ]
or
being the spare heir to Prince William's
Birthright to the throne yeah it's what
the younger brother is I mean how it
goes the young look the firstborn son is
always the favorite and the second son
is always the backup quarterback that's
just the way she goes detailing
extraordinarily personal at times pain
let him have the [ __ ] print let him
be the main Prince I mean seriously for
[ __ ] sake
ounce of growing up in the royal family
and what eventually drove him and Megan
to leave it all behind Megan yeah Megan
as discussed in this Sunday's 60 Minutes
interview with Anderson Cooper what
Megan had to go through was was similar
in some part to what okay now in what
way I'm Anderson Cooper says you know I
do not know how vaginas function I don't
know how heteronormative relationships
work have you seen the pictures of me
with my mom I mean I've been [ __ ] up
for a long time have you seen the tight
jeans me and my husband wear I don't
think you want to go that route with me
I mean you can literally see the shape
of my penis mm-hmm went through very
different circumstances question mark
didn't know that this is but then you
add in maybe that's why he's so
inquisitive
it's a natural journalist yeah the race
element which was what the Press British
press jumped on straight away I went
into this incredibly naive I had no idea
the British press was so bigoted
so you're projecting you're dressed as a
Nazi
how dare you see you you're projecting
you're projecting
what the British press was saying on to
your family
and then you believe the propaganda and
then your wife got pissed at the price
she was getting and then she started
bleeding and then you started just
projecting all that onto your family
right right the mainstream media in
England that's been pushing more
migrants to live there more people from
Somalia to move there and stuff like
that are really bigoted you're right
that's them
hell I was probably a bigoted
the relationship with with Megan you'd
think you were bigoted before the
relationship in there I was like John
Mayer my dick was like David Duke into
her yo getting hard for black chicks
doesn't mean you're not racist okay
that's coming from me it means you're
horny and you've been through all the
other races
I'm just saying
I don't know put it this way I didn't
see
what I now see what look I don't really
like grits but I'll try it we do see
among the detail personal Revelations
losing his virginity into that horse
what
huh wow you're right the local news is
wild and the field behind a pub to an
older woman
was it your mom his recreational drug
use of cannabis and cocaine
you know okay so yeah he's a teenager
and what is a More Country hey Virgie
this guy did weed and Coke now this is
the whole point of this video that I'm
playing and I want you to hear the next
sentence you ready
Kane one of the more controversial
statements in a book packed with them is
the claim that he killed 25 Taliban
members while serving in Afghanistan in
2012.
25. he's Rambo bro he wasn't on the
front line he was when these people and
people that have that have served I will
talk about is whenever you have a high
what do they call them a a a a high
priority Target which means someone that
could be potentially kidnapped and
extort like a government they're not
they're never put in a position where
that can happen they're not going to put
a British Prince on the front lines yeah
so I don't know
and also I have never met somebody who
had
like their number of kills and told
people that number out loud thank you
who I've ever believed everyone I've
ever known who have killed people don't
talk about it don't want to talk about
it as a matter of fact every and
merchandise between both of us have a
lot of friends some of them Mutual that
served in the military I mean I'm sure
there's like a rare exception it's just
some guys a sick [ __ ] right like a
comedian yeah exactly animal mother yeah
yeah exactly but for the most part most
normal people that serve if they've had
to kill somebody usually go I don't
really like talk they don't like talking
about it it makes them uncomfortable and
it's not something they definitely don't
brag about uh somebody in the rumble
chat uh jaw 411 said 25 Afghan prisoners
they lined up for them
you're right
if I've confirmed kills in eight minutes
like wow that was it's like the [ __ ]
private parts thing well I threw a
grenade in the orphanage but that only
counted as one kill because they were
kids [ __ ] 25 Taliban members while
serving in Afghanistan in 2012 breaking
an unspoken code among service members
never to discuss kills much less in
public
so he killed 25 afghanis but he couldn't
beat up his brother when they were
horsing around
I'm sorry
the British media you killed more brown
people than anybody in the [ __ ] room
and even when I've heard some stories
from
from people in the military like
sometimes they'll you know you get drunk
and they'll start telling your stories
and [ __ ] they always use like a
euphemism like if you ever hear them go
like oh and then we killed blah blah
blah or we you know killed blah blah
they neutralized like that or like so my
buddy told me a story one time about
when they got um ambushed and it was
like people they were getting shot at on
one side from a town and another side
from caves and um he was just describing
that they were pretty much pinned down
on two sides he's like and the way he
described it was man so we just started
[ __ ] dropping people like he's like
we just started we just lit that place
up man like they'll say things like we
lit that place up man we were dropping
people but it's it's like they don't
like to go killing like we're like bro
it starts shooting at us we started
[ __ ] dropping people before we got
out of there you know but that's it is
and it's it's you know it's it's [ __ ]
gross like
you he's at the same time wants us to
believe that he's a poor gentle flower
that is experiencing racism but also he
just [ __ ] straight up murdered 25
haji's and further details of the
allegations that his brother William
physically attacked him in an argument
over Megan Donna always used to say to
me that that she cheated a lot on
Charles she told me in price a lot with
her tennis pro who looks suspiciously
like Harry can we get a frozen or
somebody can we get a picture that uh uh
that uh Harry's dad that [ __ ] tennis
coach yes put it in Princess dies tennis
coach yes their details of the
allegations that his brother William
physically attacked him and also William
not Charles's kid either Andre Agassi
explains the airline
she's a tennis [ __ ]
that's so funny yeah could you imagine
yeah you know what you know like that
you know how the tennis ball is coming
when it's like Pringles looking can't
things she shoved it up her [ __ ] and
used to shoot the balls like she was a
tennis it's true I don't think that's
and she played doubles did you read the
book
I mean I'm assuming I don't know I have
no idea if that's true again this is all
coming from me moms
in an argument over Megan Diana always
used to say to me that Harry was
the promise is set up a good not to have
like 13 Joe it's just too good it's too
good this is them they knew what they
were doing come on
I always used to say to me in the butt
it doesn't count as cheating
Diana always used to say to me I can't
believe how much my Beanie Baby's gonna
be worth when I die
okay all right who's next I'll do one
right okay okay here we go okay sorry
here we go
hold on hold on hold on hold on hold on
here we go physically attacked him in an
argument over Megan Diana always used to
say to me
auto mechanic shmatto mechanic
all right everybody yeah Diana always
used to say to me that prince Andrew the
[ __ ] away from Harry
and then William both I don't want him
alone in a room with them
Diana always used to say to me if any of
if
Diana always used to say to me help I'm
on fire
[Laughter]
okay last one you have one okay your
next one should I preparing Diana always
used to say to me you know we beat the
traffic if we take the tunnel
just [ __ ] children yeah
Diana always used to say to me if any of
my children date a tar baby you
intervene immediately and break up this
family
I I have one more okay last one but then
we move on okay this is getting stupid
now okay here we go Megan Diana always
used to say to me
that Candle in the Wind songs [ __ ]
shy in it
so wait a second you turned Princess
Diana to some [ __ ] and he snatch person
well she was that Harry was the backup
to William in the nicest possible way
she she wanted Harry to be Williams
Road's an Asian if you scroll up enough
you can actually see the one where the
guy's wearing the green shirt yeah
that's literally Prince Harry
like that's that's just [ __ ] dad like
some of them are Prince Harry and the
older version of the guy who's his dad
now but if you scroll up you can see the
age-appropriate picture of the tennis
pro right next to Diana and oh my God
it's a real conundrum for the royal
family going forward so here's the part
where we say no comments calm down
Palace we have that 60 Minutes interview
that comes out this weekend the book
officially comes out next week and in an
interview here Prince Harry has refused
to comment on whether he'll be attending
his father's coronation in this
probably not but also I I think I do
think it's uh I do think it's it's funny
that at least this I will say out of all
the coverage I've seen the local news
one was my favorite one at least because
they were honest about like breaking the
code of like at least being a little
more honest about Like a Ghost Rider by
the way yeah if you want if you if we
didn't watch that and we just watched
this Good Morning America thing it would
be all like he's such
yeah my dad was how unequipped anybody
would be in that situation
and also the acceptance that or the
realization that he was undoubtedly
awake
since 1am
since the moment that he was told of a
crash he waited until he wake me up in
the morning
but for me it was really important
to be able to sketch that scene and
share with people where my story really
began where you comforted in any way I
don't think my family knew what to do
I don't think they knew what to do and I
can't maybe he wasn't comforted because
his father probably didn't know what to
do his wife just died like well she
wasn't his wife anymore right well I'm
sorry I apologize the mother of his
children just died and he's put in a
situation where he has to explain to
them that your mother died you know what
I mean
and who who was mommy's friend in the
car with her
well say whether other families would
have done a better job but I wish I had
the ability or the opportunity
to do some form of therapy or at least
to be able to talk therapy
bro what the [ __ ] man I don't remember
therapy being this I mean at any time
that I remember therapy being pushed
when I was a kid was like if it was a
really [ __ ] up kid right where it's
like look this kid's gotta talk to
someone's gonna [ __ ] shoot up the
school if he doesn't but now it's just
like that's it therapy It's All Therapy
sometimes they would send you to a
therapist at school if like your grades
were bad or you seemed like you know not
necessarily a school shooter just seemed
like if you were exhibiting like all
right this kid's having some problems at
home or something you know what I mean
then they'd be like all right they'd
send you like a therapist it was mostly
just a hey you doing all right anything
okay like your your home life all right
but nowadays it's like I gotta go work
on myself and really take stock of the
things and shut up just drink and just
push it down [ __ ] drugs and get a
hooker and calm down
losing my mom and celebrating my whole
life but well I know a little thing
about royalty because I was recently
made King of the polar bear that's true
and and the was it the puffins the
puffins King of the polar bears and the
puppy and the mole people also the mo
people that's when I went to space and
I'm negotiating with them too I'm also
the secret King of the Moon oh can you
edit that I don't want George to get mad
and then he just takes up the next 40
minutes of this interview that would be
the best that would be the best he just
talks about his experience with polar
bears do you ever used to see me playing
football when you were the kid
got football over there so one with the
feet right you play with the feet but
who's to say that at age 12 when I would
have see I could never play that because
I would just naturally want to grab on
my hand you know you can't it's how I
was trained and said yes to that you
talked about how for a while you in your
mind magical things you said she's
hiding yeah
there's no way this could have happened
to my mom she is hiding do you really
think she would hide in that tunnel
what if she just really was [ __ ] that
Saudi guy instead of being around her
kids they're telling me to stop talking
about they're still there kill my family
so I'm gonna go ahead and stop right
here with this interview
yeah I'm being told that if I get too
out of line it will not stop with my dad
um they said they're gonna give me what
are they saying that shot they gave them
all Hamlin I don't know what that means
they're gonna talk to me very quietly in
my face the way McCarthy did to Matt
Gates before he puts it out Strahan
grabs his chest Falls over and Skip
Bayless walks in off camera goes who's
in charge now bucko and he just starts
doing the interview so Harry question
should they have stopped that game I
mean come on 20 G's on it yeah I mean
Harry come on I know you're not a big
football guy but think Imagine This Is
England right and it was your world cup
or whatever you people do uh wouldn't
you be mad sitting there in a full suit
wearing a red Jordan year three Jordans
bright red exactly yeah how do I think I
feel because I lost a bunch of money on
a game that got postponed and I had to
throw out all my Yeezys I had about
fifteen thousand dollars worth of Yeezys
I had to throw out
I just bought a Balenciaga scarf too
what am I going to do with that bro I'm
telling you the minute the minute Kanye
West started going Defcon 3 on the Jews
yeah the smartest person in the world
would have went and checked dumpsters
and Skip bayless's house yes did you
know he would go check his garbage cans
the next day because you know you threw
out a lot of nice sneakers in disgust
all right I think we're done with this
um bye Puffin bye bye bye King of the
puffins he's not a puffin he's their
leader
have some respect man